[Music]  who's seen the new Bond movie Skyfall if  you watch this go yeah yeah no it opened  over the weekend it broke all box office  records getting rave reviews I I saw it  yeah we thought it was great  cool cool movie it was interesting they  shot all around London in a lot of  public spaces and I don't have to see in  the movie I thought sometimes that may  have hurt them a little bit take a look  at this scene always makes me feel  there's a melancholy what do you see  bloody good [ __ ] I'm your new  quartermaster you must be joking  [Music]  I don't know where we are now and you  have the man problem with this map  there's all things in British the  British one for back rules  [Applause]  [Music]